Where do forces come from?
All forces arise
from the interaction
of two objects with each other.
In this example, we have
two objects, One and Two,
interacting with each
other in this case
because their surfaces are in
contact with each other-- one
sitting on top of the other.
And the interaction
between the two objects
gives rise to a pair of forces.
I have one force that's acting
from object two down on object
one, and the other force
that's acting from object one
back up onto object two.
And these forces, following
Newton's third law,
are equal in magnitude
and opposite in direction.
What if we now push
these blocks horizontally
in opposite directions?
At their interface, there
is a frictional interaction.
This interaction gives rise
to a pair of frictional forces
that are parallel
to the interface.
The friction force on the top
block from the bottom block
is opposite in direction
but equal in magnitude
to the friction from the bottom
block due to the top block.
Let's look at some of the common
misconceptions about forces.
First of all, motion
is not a force.
If I have a block that's
moving at a constant velocity
along a frictionless
plane, then there's
no horizontal force that's
acting on this block.
Because there is no
interaction that would give
rise to a horizontal force.
The fact that it has a
velocity does not necessarily
mean that there is a
force acting on it.
Another common mistake
is to think that forces
transfer through objects.
For example, if I'm pushing
a book against a wall,
it might seem like
the force from my hand
is being transferred
to the wall.
But what is really
happening is that there are
two independent interactions.
The interaction of my
hand with the book.
And the interaction of
the book with the wall.
And these are
separate interactions.
The forces might happen
to have the same magnitude
in some cases.
But it's not because
the force from my hand
is being transferred.
Forces arise between
pairs of objects.
And those forces can only
act on those two objects.
Let's look more closely
at Newton's third law.
So Newton's third law says that
when there are two objects that
are interacting, there
will be two forces that
arise from that interaction.
And these two forces are always
equal in magnitude and opposite
in direction.
These two forces, this Newton's
third law pair of forces,
never act on the same object.
But instead one force acts
on the first object and one
on the second.
Because these forces arise
out of the same interaction,
they have to be the
same type of force.
So they could be gravitational
forces, frictional forces,
normal forces, et cetera.
Let's look at an example of
a book sitting on a table.
It's being pulled down by
the gravitational force.
And it's being held up
by the normal force.
Are these two forces a
Newton's third law pair?
The book is not accelerating.
So these forces are equal
in magnitude and opposite
in direction.
But they cannot be a Newton's
third law for two different
reasons.
First of all, they both act
on the same object-- the book.
And second of all, they arise
from different interactions.
The normal force on the book
is part of a Newton's third law
pair that comes
from the interaction
between the book and the table.
What's the Newton's third law
pair of the gravitational force
on the book?
Well, because the
gravitational force
arises from the interaction
between the book and the earth,
the other force in the
Newton's third law pair
is actually the force that
the book exerts on the earth.
You might not think about
the book acting on the earth.
But the force is actually equal
and opposite to the earth's
force on the book.
It's just that the earth
is so much more massive,
the force has no
detectable influence
on the Earth's behavior at all.